They no idea. Kind of nervous.
Here we go. Here we go.
Bam. What a boy's gonna have to be smart.
A lot of footwear to south paws too.
And other big point. Here we go. Get
the size of tils. Fucking thighs.
Boy.
Their styles look at their styles.
Both real loose but more moitai based
with till he's going to throw a frog lake
round kicks. The thing about wonder
boys, he's all light on the toes.
His trigger is insane
leg kick right away by till.
Very interesting.
I'm so curious about this fight. She
that video til put out of him sparring.
Just beating the shit at some guy. Yeah,
it was weird, right? Yeah. Very strange.
Yeah, that good. But he knocked
him out. Hurting him too.
I wouldn't post that if I was
him. Yeah. And then you know,
he posted some of him getting hit too
after that because he said people are
calling him a bully that I don't like
because that means he's reading the
comments and then he's
reacting to those comments,
which means people can fuck with this
guy. If you're a young fighter, to me,
tough men to navigate through,
well those comments,
you got to leave them alone because
there's so many you're dealing with, uh,
you know,
a pool of thousands and thousands of
people and who knows who they are or what
their peak yet. But also a lot of those
people aren't happy for your success.
I know Ms. Brown, their
life, so they come of course,
especially a guy like Tim was on the rise,
you know,
or anyone in the spotlight tries
that switch kick off the front leg.
UFC might want to hire just wanting
to help these younger guys with that.
Well just give him a little psychological
counseling on how to handle it and get
a social media expert in their tills
are going to close the distance in land.
That left hand over the top.
Wonderboy is not there though. Yeah.
What a boys footwork.
It's fricking ridiculous.
Well this is the perfect kind of style
ram to an aggressive guy coming forward.
This is what he's used to have. I have
to imagine that's why it took the fight.
Just stylistically, he's like, yeah,
big guy. Aggressive. Let's do it right.
Yeah. Even though remarried, just be
Mazda doll who he's see Wonderboy,
he shouldn't be there. Right. He
better get the fuck out of there.
Don't stay there. Yeah.
He loves that leg kick,
but he was a little off balance
and he didn't recuperate. Well,
Darren made a shift as he was going to
launch that leg kick and he put them in a
weird position where he was off balance.
I mean there's some good adjustments
going on here at both guys.
Trying to find the right day. What? Oh
Shit. God till likes to fire one aleks.
That slide with the right hand forward
and then look off to the left hop.
You good? Oh Shit. One,
two quick one to Wonderboy,
letting them know it's still there. Boy
has that a finished. It's still there.
It looks tilt. Tilt. A little
hesitant now. Wait a little bit.
Now be careful like a
cobra man. Be careful. Oh,
you're talking about dude who was
like 57 and o was a kickboxer.
Good wonder by agreement as
far as high level striking.
I can't remember the last time two
strikers were matched up this, well, no,
and this is five round son.
Ooh. I'll take, Ooh. Yeah.
Who knows what's going to happen and
that's fine. This is interesting. So,
so there's high level. I'm just trying
to figure out with the left hand.
Pop them with the left hand is
caught him at the end event.
Not a lot of power but reached him.
Yeah.
He's letting tell know that
he's down there. Yup. Snap.
He's also switching legs,
switching stances now he's all sideways.
It's hard to find a trading partners.
Get to emulate Wonderboy. Man.
You don't really get a real look at ou.
He's picking his shots. I think he's
trying to frustrate till so till jumps in.
Makes them, Ooh, looked for it.
I don't think that landed though. Huh?
No, look cool though. And I was onboard.
I yelled out. You got to get off
the cage chair. He got to get out.
Yeah. I think for one of where these first
two rounds, just try to frustrate till,
yeah.
What time is it in England right now?
There's seven hours ahead or they eight
eight so it's fucking eight o'clock it's
really late Thursday at eight o'clock
eight 30 at night or they see,
I see. I think it's seven
30 it's eight hours. Is it?
Trust me. Yeah. You probably
know. So it's 9:30 PM right now.
Eight 30 bro.
Eight 30 what time is it now?
1230 I looked at my watch broken unless
there's a couple different times zones
in the UK.
I thought it was just one and I have
daylight savings time or something.
Nobody should have that shit dead.
Arizona does it right? They do.
They're like, fuck you fuck with
it. And not our sleep we lose.
Got Real fuck yourself. Two year old.
But how about when you gain that hour?
It's nice when you gain it for
like two days. Not worth it, bro.
It's not worth it in the morning.
It's dark in the afternoon.
It's not your boys too. Yeah. Yeah.
Mike six got a grown man.
He's all into Harry Potter and Shit now.
That's crazy. Damn we got it.
We got a universal studios.
How often have you haven't been,
you haven't been a universal studios.
You need to go universal studios.
Fucking brules now the three
d simulations. Hell yeah.
High level that that Harry Potter ride
at Disney is pretty sick. Yeah, I was
straight up scared on that. Right?
I was scared.
That transformer ride is amazing.
Also in [inaudible] land is sick
or rides ever. You know what's the
best ride ever? All time. Hands down.
Flights of passage.
Avatar ride in Disney world in Orlando.
I went to the simulation. It's
incredible, dude. It's incredible.
It's like virtual reality. You go in, you
sit on this bike, you're riding a dragon,
you saw Avatar,
right?
You're riding one of those things
through the fucking jungle.
It is every is think of like,
have you ever done that?
There's the thing at Disney land called
soaring over the world, will you?
It's amazing.
Giant screen and you're flying like over
India and over the Everest. It's amaze.
Sure. That's not Disney world
or they've got, no, it just
did. It just did. He said,
yeah. Disney world. Disney land has
soaring over the world. Oh, but oh,
here we go. Round to fuck
world around. I remember,
Oh till we get a little more aggressive,
tagged him with that left
hand and that castle,
that Bet Harry Potter castle that they
build. What the fuck? That's amazing. No,
it's incredible. Tills getting
way more amped up. Oh Shit. Ooh.
One mistake man. I know Wonderboy
is such a good counter fighter.
Oh he lives where it done.
Oh gotta get off the fucking fence.
That's all till once.
So that first round you got to
give it to one or boy, right? Yeah.
I mean it's super close, but yeah. Yeah,
give it to Wonderboy. The Wonderboy,
not a whole lot going on. Most of them.
And he landed like maybe two shots.
One of the body, one to
remember this though. They're
in Liverpool, the home kit.
He's the hometown kid and the
judges look at a octagon control,
so it's not necessarily
could give to wonder. Boom,
that that front my ground until
I don't think landed anything,
but he's going forward and the judges
are morons. So like, oh, going forward.
That works well.
Give it to till he did a good job.
Didn't t they always ask a
question after they say something.
He's amazing. Isn't he
fantastic, right hand, wasn't it
the side tried to get
loose in the third round.
I feel like it's getting
looser ready a little bit.
It's just such a dangerous chess game.
I know.
And Wonderboy hands motherfucking
down son. He's always
like that. It's like that.
That's that karate style sign.
Okay.
Ooh, look for it till slid, slid to the
right tills. Elbows are no joke either.
Now if he gets in close, they're the one
that he landed on. Cowboy was ruthless.
God, who else has he beaten? It's
about it. So yeah, I'm really, uh,
in,
he hasn't really,
he hasn't really knocked you off
your socks before that cowboy fight.
He's at some decisions. Hmm.
Yeah. We still need knockout.
You stopped somebody to know yet early
on he had one stop. It's, Oh shit. Ooh.
Damn. Wonderboy. Wonderboy
top a very smart man. Yeah.
Well this is like,
again,
stylistically such a great fight because
this is the style that Wonderboy really
does.
Like he likes to God,
that's Uber aggressive and when it turned
in terms of like high level technique,
both these guys are really
good. Really, really good.
Don't till till keeps throwing that
front like so kicked to the frontline.
Oh Gosh. No, we wanted to do
a little short with Yep. Ooh.
Hixon yeah, he doesn't mind. Oh boy. He's
going to have to adapt to that. Yeah,
they both switch it up.
Don't, Yup. Oh, Ooh.
Just missed that head kick son.
But uh,
miss financial is as good as a mile.
Tim Scott.
Great Distance Control.
They both do delete that. Do
they bought two? Don't they?
Don't they don't they? That's Irish,
isn't it? I don't know. My accent. SOC,
we need a high natto in here.
I have some scouts for us.
Amazing Kid. Definitely a different
accent to it. The thick man. Yeah.
Sunderland, Liverpool, thick ass.
Liverpool I think is Ozzy Osborne.
Okay.
Oh, Russian in man. Why do boy loves
to do that? Like switch slit splits.
Yeah, but it's, it's so,
it's so hard to figure out what the fuck
he's going to do because he switched
his stance as well. He does it sometimes
and then we'll throw a kick. Yeah,
he's back to Russia and again, tills just
trying to figure out and pin him down.
But here it's not there. I wonder how this
is, this is one of the boys game plan,
man Kimmy up commit and make a mistake.
They should capitalized but tills doing
a good job of not giving them much space
where the cages,
this is not happening in the center
of the cage as much as it's Ha.
Oh wonderful. I'll try that. Sweat,
chills going to feel any pressure.
Get a finish cause till is absolutely
controlling the center of the cage.
They under void does not have a lot.
Well now they're in the center and you,
you know that wins rounds
for these judges. Yeah.
Cause they don't understand fighting.
That place is packed too man.
Oh I'm sure they say, you know,
he's a superstar superstar
and be the face of the,
of uh, England man.
Big knockout here. It'd be the fit cause
Bisbing IFC is, but if he's retired,
yeah. Who else is coming up
in England? Uh, we got uh,
Michael Van and page, right? Sure. Yeah,
but he's not, he's not on this level.
Well, why don't they give him high level
fights? He just had fought a Rickles.
Do you see what he did to
him? No. Fucked him up.
I heard he exploded his face
and choked him out. Yeah.
And I was like his first like they
weren't feeding him, you know,
like that was a tough fight.
Mike van page daily.
Next they say and, and, and
Roy MacDonald. Musashi. Ooh,
those are two very good
fights. I really, me,
I really like page daily cause
they don't like each other.
They fucking hate each other.
I liked that fight.
I'll watch shout out to all the
10 plan of schools in the UK.
We got like a eight now. Damn Lung,
10 30 lunch. This neighborhood.
How many cranberry Redditch Darlington.
Uh,
Shit. Am I missing one? Oh, glass
gal. That's Skorton Scotland.
How many got worldwide? About a
hundred. That's amazing. It's crazy.
Amazing Ooze. And it keeps
growing, man. It keeps growing.
He hit him with that psychic and a,
you see wonder boys leg Bacall she's
out in the replay. He didn't like that.
[inaudible] with three straight. Yeah.
One of them really made his knee buckle.
Ma'Am. Those things fucking sorry.
Here it is Michael Van and page.
We'll kicked him.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
Damn. Oh, he's so fast.
That's again the karate.
He comes from that point
fighting background. You know,
there's a great karate match
that I watched. I mean,
I don't know how many times
they fought, but on, um, uh,
they fought point fighting way back in
the day. Um, Raymond Daniels and Michael,
then a page for each other and fighting.
Now Raymond Daniels is the glory champion
and Michael Van and Paige is coming up
in Beltour. Very interesting. Oh, he's
a belt or champion now. Raymond Daniels,
right. He left glory.
[inaudible] here we go.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Here we go,
Darren till super aggressive here.
Now I wonder if a Wonderboy,
his knee is okay because those, uh,
he still hasn't landed anything now
except for those sidekicks to the knee.
Is Atlanta anything to the head?
Nothing. Wonderboy, his knee seems fine.
He's moving fine tooth around so
far. No shot to the head. Yeah.
Ooh,
kick to the body.
Well,
the whole thing with Wonderboy is just
you make a mistake and he counters you
and so far till hasn't really made any
mistakes but wonder boys found a few
openings but there's never been like one
big bum rush where he'd left a gap and
Wonderboy could drop a ball on him.
Did I miss anything?
Nope. Nothing. But they did show the
replay. The knee buckling a Wonderboy.
It look pretty now. Yeah. From what? From
that sidekick. Oh Wow. From a side kick.
Front leg side kick to me.
But he's moving fine.
It doesn't seem like he's a limping at
all and he threw some kicks with that
left leg. So it would be nice at one
one. It's hard to tell. It's hard.
Wonderboy was a little more
aggressive though. Yeah,
I wouldn't be getting knocked
out. Knocked out. You think so.
Same thing with the Woodley
five who was like, oh,
be more aggressive and get
fucking starched by Woodley.
That isn't a real fighter.
A, it's still, you got to,
well this is his style man. This is
his style. His style is move around,
but the thing is until is so high level
as well that it's hard for this style to
even find its home. You
know, you have an aggressive,
which counter striker this is, I don't
know what people expect. Really. Machida.
Yeah. How about that? My cheat
at front kick to vittores fails.
Dariana Cheetah. How fucking
dare you know. Ooh, the
man's sign off fighting went,
you know what? Enjoy the retirement.
Hey Josh. Yeah. Crazy, right?
That was the one, the worst knockouts
effort and it just walks off fucking,
it starts praying and you see the
photo of the foot on the face.
Text book,
front kick balls of the balls of the feet.
You think feature goes to ride just juices
with every Brazilian drug ever. Uh, my,
my heart hope so too.
I pray for that at night.
I pray for golden like Masters Division.
Yeah,
just go off and want to see
veins in his teeth against.
It's crazy that he's still
fighting Jesus Christ and his gums.
And he was around in the early days.
He's the only guy from the
early day still fight. Oh yeah.
Wonderboy caught him with that right hand,
man.
You could say the same thing for Dan
Henderson, but he's officially retired.
He's retired.
But Wonderboy,
I mean a [inaudible] was around a UFC 12.
That's crazy.
Henderson was around in 98 so it
wasn't much longer afterwards.
You know. Crazy. Really.
They fought, right?
Dan Henderson and killed him both times.
Yup.
Oh, oh, we caught all right. And See
till starting to get anxious here.
This one's gonna get in trouble,
man.
Ooh. Well he's looking for
wonder. Boy gets baked. Kale
is the his legs, man. I mean,
his hands are dangerous for his
powers in those fucking legs. Oh Shit.
He's found that head kick a few times.
A sick slip,
but till who does till train with,
I don't know much about his
to come bone and live a pool.
Uh, his coaches calling,
I forget his last name.
It's crazy one or boy's dad crane's
him, right? Yeah, it'd be tough dynamic.
Ooh Damn that. Not everyone
is no touch. Just touch them.
But he didn't touch him at the very
end with that a round kick to the face,
he might be fine and an opening for that
one to blitz out till just tagged him
with that job.
I have a hard time believing in these
judges. I don't have it. Three nothing.
Right, right in Liverpool
dock to gun control. Well,
judges are two, right?
Or the American judges.
The English judges are all morons though,
aren't they all around the world?
Unfortunately.
I love the fact that you could say that
you don't work for anybody. I know.
Isn't it cool? And you
can have no written.
Oh no till. Got poked in the
eye. Get the fuck Outta here.
Mark gutters were worried about
an eye poked in anybody. That boy,
that doctor got in that room quick.
That doctor just jumped in. God,
where did he come from?
And now he's out.
He's trying to get a little
too much TV time. Oh yeah.
Oh definitely.
I don't mean to poke or Reno.
Oh, they were booing him.
Yeah. He's saying no, no. Boom.
Oh Shit. Sometimes I poked really
rev a dude up or a Dick Kik.
Oh my damn till. Get wild here. You
know. Don't get too comfortable. Okay.
There you go. On over
the top. Oh Shit. Oh. Oh.
He's getting crazy here
dude.
That I poke.
Really poke him.
I wish you would have poked nine the
first round or the round here. Oh, not,
I was trying to get loose. That's
about to get fun. That was three,
so we've got two more to go. Thank
God this is a five rounder. Right?
That will stretch me. Pissed. Yeah,
you'd feel so. I talk so much.
Shit on that fight is three
rounds. It ended there. Yeah,
man.
Yes.
That dude has a prominent forehead
cheekbone situation going on.
I think gang is kind. Got a little
bit of that. A little bit of,
it's definitely got some fucking
ancient man and I'm a, he does.
I don't look like him. He
definitely boom. That right hand.
That was the nice the
counter. I'm here. Boom,
boom. Oh, that got him. Definitely. He
slept with it. Yeah. He went with it,
but it caught him at the end of it for
sure. Look what I done. I'm like tired.
This is his style. You know, he's
so efficient at doing that. Oh,
both these guys can do this for 10
rounds. Yeah. Round Four. Here we go.
God, it's, this is a fight.
That is a great argument for the
five round fight for high level.
Maybe we would feel so bad if we were
leaving here and then, yeah. Like who won?
Who cares what even happened?
Like what, what are the stats on?
Oh Dude. Enlist trenches
and kicks. Landed. Yeah.
Unless you're super and you'd be so
wonderful. It was a hard jab. Right.
Their kid didn't tilt better. Watch his
p's and q's though. You are too hard, man.
Yup.
But
juice is worth the squeeze
if can get it knocked down.
Okay.
Oh, Ooh. Damn.
This is getting hot.
Yeah. Cause Yeah. Daren tills
never been five rounds. How's
he? No, I don't think so.
He hasn't switched in the EOC.
This first made it well,
first times because his main event against
cowboy Jase starch cowboys, he has it.
Yeah. That's his first main event.
Right. And what about outside of the UFC?
How many fights he had a,
he had what?
17 or a 14 on crazy speaks
perfect Portuguese. Oh,
does he? I didn't know that. Oh yeah,
man, when he fucked Darren till I tan,
this kid's marketable when
he fought in Brazil. Uh, he,
he spoke Portuguese to the crowd. He lived
there for like 10 years. Right? Yeah.
I watched one of his, uh, older fights
when we stop this guy and he, uh,
spoke Portuguese to the crowd after the
fire, the guy up 10 fights were there.
Wow. Yeah, he went there.
It just went to live down.
That had to get on to Liverpool cause I
guess there's little talks that form we
got stabbed. Yeah. Yes. That,
yeah. You can see the stem mark.
Where is it a lower like on his,
uh, on his rights dab in Brazil,
but right above his hip in England, in
Liverpool, in his hometown. And his coach,
his coach told him, Hey, you
gotta get Outta here man.
If you want to continue to have their
knives and the you can often off.
How many more people got to
get stuff that's, you know,
the London mayor actually said that
if you get caught with a knife,
he'd be prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law.
What about if I had an open
boxes? Princesses, brother-in-law,
her brother got caught with one when he
went over there for the royal wedding
last week. Oh, that you
got caught with a knife.
They said he took one because Trump said
that you should take one with him and
he was in a bar. God. Oh, he's crazy.
Is he crazy? Her brother's crazy.
She's a dime piece man.
Okay.
I'm assuming you to Deb. Nothing. No,
I'm watching it. It's fine. Your son,
one boy with a step in Jab.
Not a lot of action. This fighting. Oh,
Wonderboy looking for that left hand
over the top because it land. Nope.
Just kind of grazed him. It's kind
of hard to tell his back was to us.
It's can be a tough fucking
fight to judge, man.
Tell us having a hard time hitting him.
That's for damn sure. Beautiful Duck.
Under that, we get this tail with a
clinch. What if he takes him down to,
we just stopped the fight. Interestingly,
the tills, the one holding onto him here.
Oh, elbow that clinches. Mortised nasty.
Good elbow on the break there.
You're one of my say exactly what he
wanted. That light's kind of fucked up.
That lead leg, right leg. Yup. It
does look a little bruised. Oh Oo.
Good kicks to the body. I mean, yeah.
You guys watched that show Cobra Kai? No,
I haven't seen, I've heard close
to be good. Yeah. No, it's great.
That's a crazy well on Wonderboy.
His leg.
I really haven't noticed him
getting hit that much either.
It's on both legs to the office.
See the right legs worse would
that left leg is pretty tender.
Ronnie to the right leg
looks really fucked us.
I don't really remember
him kicking that heart.
It must have been when he was standing
in South Park, sideways, you know,
and now he hasn't gotten back then. Hathi
really not mine. Let's just round it.
Doesn't like it. Oh my God. Yeah.
I mean his footwork just stupid.
So Darren till can't really
get a read on him. But again,
the judges are given that the till.
Yeah,
that nothing big has happened where
you go all that guide. Definitely.
If someone knock someone down,
you've got the fight.
It shows Mike Lp got the
good right hand to the body.
So such a high level chess
game here, which I dig it.
I'm on the edge of my seat.
But if you're just a regular
fan like come on man.
I'll tell you what he's going
to get more shit is Wonderboy.
Cause there's one Woodley fights.
Which thoughts are not his fault.
It's not his fault. I'm just saying the
public thing. Iom Shit, I guess. I Dunno.
It's what it is. It's this is
the, I mean you want to beat him.
You got to come after him
and he'd come after him.
You run into the woods shipper.
But the thing is he's not
winning when he does this,
but we didn't win against Woodley
when he did this for sure.
But his wife obviously, he's
obviously got number one for a reason.
He's number one in the world happened
there at that back leg is fucked up man.
Yeah, I'll do friendly Boyce will. Yeah,
he's wobbling a little on the back to
his corner. That leg is fucked up man.
Maybe they just get it loosened this
fifth round and just save it for the fifth
round. Eddie. I hope
so. Me Too. Cause again,
if it stopped right here I'd be bummed
out. I'm feeling pretty lack luster.
Yeah,
I was really cross going to give it to
till oh 100% know that every round of
that gift to my that and then once you,
it's like we don't want to like make it
too obvious and he gives one to one a
boy. I don't know. I'd say he's
up. He's up three to one till.
Really? Because of the judges. Yes. But
the judges of what you think. Right?
Uh, even that it'd be tough.
You can maybe go to two,
but I would say tills winning this fight.
I don't know about that.
I think Wonderboy is winning. Can I get
some Goddamn copy? Strike numbers, Fox.
I know. No wonder they left her ass.
Just kidding. Can I get something?
How's your show going on showtime?
Enjoying it? Yeah. It's been good, man.
It's been fun.
Nice to a lot of fun.
Did you know that guy that just died
without from the comedy division? Yeah,
I did not. Did you know? Everybody
seems to think he's, I might've met him,
but everybody seems to think he's a
really good guy. That sucks, man. 55 man.
I know. Such a shame. Crazy.
Burt. Love the Gar. Oh yeah.
Yeah. I burned up some real nice to say
about also the dice. That's a bummer man.
Yeah. [inaudible] super
aggressive here coming off of you.
I'm sure he wants to get the finish.
Probably feels a little bit of pressure
and you should.
Okay. They're saying Darren
tills corns very urgent.
Like he's losing the fight.
No,
I think he's losing. You do. Yeah. Yeah.
I think if I would count up all the
different strikes strikes that landed.
Yeah. I think a lot of this,
according to the UFC thing,
I don't know in terms of strikes landed,
it says 48 to 42 God damn,
that's tough to judge. Yeah.
That's impossible. And then
you have one aggressor,
right? And Liverpool. I
got two or three. Two,
one five rounds. 48 strikes
landed. That is just bananas.
Bananas let a defense going on. Yeah.
A lot of missing as well. Movement.
Which tiles right hand you
think would for a great,
a little jab to the grill.
Face.
Sidekick.
No one's really going balls to the wall.
Or they know
Darren till would go balls to the walls,
but wonderful. It keeps moving. It's hard.
Fucking writing. Keeps moving. Don't get
blasted in the face. Yeah, it's hard.
What did we come on man, just sit there.
What was that about? He threw a Shitty,
we'll kick and then shook his head
and then they touch gloves. It's fun.
Fucking weird. Oh, switched up on them.
It's two are a little too friendly for my,
and he's looking to set up his
wheel kick with his left leg.
Someone throws something.
Anything the crowds like. Yeah.
That you have on their w w till,
but he doesn't.
Oh there he landed a lefthand.
Why are they touching?
What do I want to touch?
Dab Cause got all the goddamn corner.
Oh is that about gorillas? Don't act
like that. I don't understand this.
That does touch gloves.
Again, too much respect.
I know there's not enough
killer instinct in this.
He's looking for that low fake and then
go with the high round kick off the
front leg.
He does that sometimes,
but he didn't do it and you just want
to know how many miles they've ran this
goddamn fight. You kind of give it
to them for sticking to their phone.
No one's getting out of composure here to
pros. Pros, I get the style. You don't,
you don't want to risk it. But if, yeah,
if you're not balls deep in a fighting,
you're not happy with this
fight. No, not thrilled with it.
This is one of the most
uneventful big events.
Who good jabs by till.
Oh Guillotine.
Oh He, I thought, Oh shit,
that's enough to win the fight.
100% that's all you need.
It don't get drop time to go a
little bit of time to go. Damn.
How hard does that motherfucker hit?
They didn't look like it. Atlanta,
like behind the air.
We'd have to look at it in the replay,
but I look or you heard him? I wonder.
Boy has got to move his ass now.
He lost the fight. Well wonder boy's
in trouble now. He's flat footed. Yeah.
What are ways to be a little bit
trouble? It's what? Till lifts where
Damn Wonderboy would've went to
till just out arrange for it to hurt.
This got interesting. That's for sure.
Proud man. Everyone's on their feet now,
but this is like wonder boy when he
fought Tyron Woodley to right. Got Tagged,
got hurt and then people
rushing get dealt with.
Look at this Wonderboy
to fucking take down.
Awesome.
No Shit.
Anything exciting when someone shoot
for a take down or these stills? Yeah.
Oh no wait,
left
Wonderboy still dangerous.
Crazy,
right?
40 seconds off. Boys. Who till just thinks
he has in the bag? I don't think so.
I just think he doesn't want to get
tagged coming in. He's a little tired too.
Mouth's open.
Hasn't been a high pace.
There's been a lot of foot work though.
So you might be a little boy.
You got to rent.
Remember till did have a real
hard time cutting that weight.
Oh and he's been going through a lot.
You're right.
They need some get downs in
it. You Ain't, you ain't,
you ain't lying. No standups.
Just get down. Get down.
Thanks.
Yeah, there's no way can give one a boy
the flat after that. It'd be hard pressed.
Especially in Liverpool.
It's over a man until one of
boys in a tough spot though.
I don't know why he's not
happy about that. That was um,
I mean he landed a good shot.
I guess he was trying,
it wasn't like he wasn't trying.
Yeah, he was sort of unfolded.
Where would you rank till after that
lackluster performance cause he,
cause Wonderboy is number one.
You'll make him number one obviously.
I think you put them in the top. Waterboy
is just a nightmare for everybody.
He's a nightmare for everybody.
It's tough to look good against him.
Oh win over him as,
as a win.
You know he beat you with a baseball
bat number one while he didn't even make
the weight.
So that's,
that's where it gets tricky because
it gives a fuck about that. Right,
but you're saying that they fought here.
Here's that front leg side kick that
wobbled his knee. Good job. Metro pcs.
A blocking the vision. God Damn it.
Metro pcs. Why would they do that?
Why would they have that right where you
need to see, I'll tell you right now,
if you're my friend, you have metro pcs.
We are not friends anymore. Knocked down,
knocked down. Do you get angry
with just because of that? Well No,
I can hang you because the cricket
wireless cell phones now cricket.
Oh Shit.
Hard fucking left hand.
Boom. Right bye. That was
legit. Not One of the fight.
He clobbered them right there behind the
air. Huh? That was as legit as it gets.
That's the most, that was the legit
shot of the fire. Like one legit shot.
That's why like if you have 49 other
strikes at land, do they even count?
I mean that. That's a real, strike that.
Do you ever use the word clobber when,
when you're calling fights? I
don't call fights. Cooperates.
Clobbers nine my addiction. You know
it's too old school collaborating.
Clobbered him cooperating.
Collapsed.
The thing says that, right? Yeah.
If the thing for Claude
tasks for clobbering time
guy, you need to bring that
up. So what do we think here?
What do you think you think until
100% for one till close to switching.
I think til split. Someone's going to
give it to Wonderboy tills. Some rebel,
some rebel. He wants to die in Liverpool.
I want to get caught on my shield.
They place that where they set that
place on fire. If do give to Wonderboy,
Liverpool Games card and the paint,
you know there's some hooligans
then it's going to be a tough,
it's going to be a tough exit strategy.
Is that a [inaudible]?
Where the fuck her name is she the in
there? Adelaide bird fly her out there.
You never know. She's seen everywhere
fucker. Does she go everywhere? Yeah.
She like gives lessons
on judging and stuff.
You don't think they put her in
there for a reason. You know,
cause she don't give a fuck.
So didn't do it on purpose.
I think day w they want um,
controversy.
Do you want people to get
used to fucked up decisions?
What we're used to it that's, yeah,
I've done this work. I think they,
they want that because if they
ever needed to pull something out,
like something was like, dude, this
motherfucker has to win. You know,
people are like, oh it is Vegas, Vegas,
Seattle boxing's corrupt as ship.
But with MMA, I just think they
don't know what they're looking at.
They don't understand west. Correct.
They just don't know either way.
It sort of thing saying, oh
here we go. Here we go. Jamie,
can you give us some volume
split?
It's a sport for be a killer Strip club.
Dj
46 and 49
unanimous.
Oh
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Boy, he didn't even need that knocked
down. It's a big fight for him.
What were some of those scores?
I can hear it.
(494) 074-0840 seven or
494649464847 well that's,
that's a big victory for him,
that's for sure.
You pointed Wonderboy
for you.
What does it feel like you're on your way?
I think you said something bad.
Thank you. Some potty language there.
What do you think?
I mean,
strategic point.
Did you expect it to go the distance?
Did you think it was gonna be like the
whole boy? I didn't. Yeah, I played games.
I don't leave. It kicks. I'm
going to go. Stuff like that.
Well classified to have such
a specific way of talking.
I feel like it's so much cooler when
they talk like this is a fighter. Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
I'm looking shoulder.
I'm going to fold this way.
Not really. Really. I'd
have to him. Yeah. Yeah.
Yes.
What is he saying?
What are they saying?
Boy? Fucking censorship.
Yeah. Well, let me,
let me hear the Bjorks next said
everyone. Anyone? I don't care.
Yeah. People ask him. Maybe you might
disable Tanya. She'll talk to them.
God Damn.
What the censorship?
Yeah.
ESPN. Please let these guys
swear. Please. Come on.
They're not going to let it. No Way.
It's going to be worse than he owns ESPN.
That's true.
Good call.
I think they might not even let
me do commentary over there.